depuis 35 ans fabregas et la coccinelle
chaque année elle reçoit quelques
aménagements mais le docteur porsche va
reconnaîtrez toujours comme stafim
moteur à l'arrière et refroidissement
par air
et puis la masse des automobilistes a
voulu des voitures plus grandes mais
volkswagen n'avait jamais réussi à
donner la coccinelle une grande soeur
attrayante
alors abandonnant toutes les traditions
fox maghen sort là qu'à 70 sa première
traction avant une berline cinq places à
l'intérieur 'sauver' mais complet son
moteur 16 centimètres cubes 4 cylindres
en ligne refroidissement par eau
développe 90 chevaux et l'entraînent à
160 km le prix entre treize mille francs
et 15000 francs
mais là qu'à 79 ans pas l'abandon de la
coccinelle
il ne s'agit absolument pas de l'abandon
de ce qui a toujours été votre principe
de fabrication propulsion arrière police
mans par r mais simplement d'une
ouverture que nous apportons sur la
gamme de modèles que nous faisons notre
clientèle à quel genre de conducteur
vous conseillé de choisir plutôt la
traction avant que la traction arrière
bien nous n'allons pas orienter le choix
de nos clients vers l'une ou l'autre de
ces deux conceptions
mais ce que nous voulons en présentant
la cahc 70 c'est permettre justement à
notre clientèle traditionnelle qui est
roulé jusqu'à présent en coccinelle qui
est un peu l'image de marque de
volkswagen de pouvoir choisir une
voiture de cylindrée supérieure de
conception différente avec un stylisme
qui est maintenant tout à fait au goût
du jeu
ce qui ne sera pas dit chez volkswagen
c'est que là qu'à 70 ce n'est qu'une
fille adoptive
elle était déjà prête à sortir l'année
dernière mais sous la bannière nsu est
née sur l'un des derniers constructeurs
indépendants d'europe a été rachetée par
le groupe volkswagen mercedes
il ne restait alors pour accroître la
gamme v v cas remplacer l'écusson nsu
par le sigle qui fleurit sur le capot
des coccinelles le tour était joué
mais cela confirme la difficulté pour
volkswagen de créer une nouvelle voiture
après vingt ans de léthargie de son
bureau d'études
et cela semble indiquer aussi que chez
volkswagen on adopte la même stratégie
que chez les autres constructeurs
européens
on préfère maintenant présenter aux
clients une gamme complète que quand tu
es sur un modèle unique
sur la route la voiture est sûr et comme
beaucoup de traction avant elle passe
mieux les grandes courbes et nationale
que les virages serrés des petites
routes des alpes on craint elle est
confortable mais un peu bruyante à la
tendance à se coucher en virage qui peut
être désagréable pour les passagers elle
représente ce que doit demander une
berline 500 centimètres cubes un
automobiliste aujourd'hui mais cependant
allemand cap d'originalité originalité
qui a permis à la coccinelle de se
vendre à 10 millions d'exemplaires
[Musique]